welcome to this video Kappa Kappa
linköping coupling ping well that's a
huge rating difference and see what we
get him and many really strong players
recently but and I didn't lose had a
really good squad recent games now maybe
this guy is ending this run yeah if we
check this mmm come on it's funny let's
check I didn't lose a game for quite a
while here so trying to keep this keep
this run pen okie dokie so yeah I can't
play let's play aggressively with my
wacky nightline is this one of those
cases i don't know i'm going to try 98
an f5 but defies i'm quite maybe that
wasn't the greatest sport ever to get
this in home yeah don't like that too
much f5 he will just take or not f5 if
he takes i have d 5 that this should be
playable f5 de 5 fe for rookie 40 fe5
twin da droopy aid and at the end I'm
winning this maybe I can play that it
was kind of wacky but let's try that at
the end I have worked you on winning the
bishop very long line I am yeah i was
thinking i should be okay and to be
honest maybeee for as a movie for Luke
takes d5 looks strange
efore d 5ef at totally bonkers that's
fun come on it's a fun game let's do it
like that takes ago d 5 & D 5 D 50 after
d5 can I go nite a five and then you can
take you for any right rocky d 50
hahahaha I never consider this move wow
I just takes my undeveloped night here
cool what a move I did not think about
it at all okay if I take here Bishop you
six down oh great okay next it's really
really really a crazy development him
okay and what is this material I seven
against seven okay but g2 we will get
he's a pawn up amazingly enough okay
my ideas bishop d 697 trying to get this
pawn back not sure about all of that
difficult stuff you can go Bishop g5 as
well
97 maybe is this on f6 is not not really
that strong maybe rookie five that looks
a bit strange but maybe it's working
nights e6 rook takes d5 but compute the
register smooth but okay if I see it you
can see it as well probably despite the
rating now he did see the move huh
remarkable so what now I have to cover
this stuff yeah if you try to go to f6
cm
still a pawn down a strange double pond
which is not in itself such a big deal
but it limits my position so much this
is the problem really it's not so much
that it is a material thing let's try it
from 95 years of night age six though
can I get this end yeah but he won't
take probably if you would take I'm kind
of okay I guess hmm I don't know
goodnight g5 coming 95 I don't every
don't know it looks bad it just looks
bad
95 Bishop EA them it's the only only way
to continue this okay hmm
unless he's winning immediately I'm kind
of not too scared of that 96 on what is
he doing rookie 796 problem wow what a
game is this guy's could totally totally
pressurizing me here hey Bishop takes g8
this is the move that I overload
and I had to head to c5 it wasn't it
wasn't a big issue anyway yeah maybe
maybe 95 year okay Quincy aid Quincy
eight might hold okay sure it's not
exactly fun this pollution
when I saw not g5 but what can you do
him 1970s going now g-49 morning okay
yeah can one take the bloody a change
come on just take it yeah amazing and
this guy is totally clobbering me here
with this 1900 rating but he played it
really well what can you do now ok check
the route to a chance is so easy
technically that you will definitely
manage now wanted to take check blah oh
yeah to end the game against this kind
of rating is kind of kind of stupid but
Bishop G idea what a move Bishop g8 that
I did not didn't see that one coming I
after I mean maybe it's not so bad but
it's very weird stuff should change what
a strange position very difficult to pi
am and that's what this was my original
intention to play before then maybe this
is what I should do I mean I was just
thinking if I was probably just better
you know but I did not ever consider
taking this yeah can do if it's not
undeveloped and moved it a couple of
times but it is it is a concrete good
move problem yeah so we should form
yeah who p5 her this is a good move
Larry is playing number one stock fish
all the time not that he's cheating i'm
not saying that he didn't but Jim it's
just very very strongly played here he
played a different move and it keeps
just that you that use such huge
pressure on black I was kind of relieved
when I get the got the light squared
Bishop traded but it's still a totally
rotten position simply because of the
light squares I know I just played a
shuffle yeah implicates no idea yeah I
have no idea in this position what I can
do f3 was a good prophylactic move and
I'm just I'm just sitting here don't
that was yeah he finally found my damn
phone so yeah he just killed me what can
i say i have to have to simply play d5
here and this is kind of an calea he
moves the bishop somewhere i go e4 take
here this is the idea I'm sorry with the
bishop here and this is kind of unclear
the situation okay well I'm interesting
game thanks for watching